more about running you studied a tribe
in Mexico it was bizarre I was on
assignment for the New York Times
magazine in Mexico and Chihuahua and I
was flipping through a magazine and I
see a picture of what it looks like to
me an old man in a dress wearing these
like wacky little sandals and the
caption says he was 55 years old and he
had won a 100-mile race through the
Rocky Mountains wearing those sandals
and I'm reading this thing thinking all
right there's at least three lies here
no 55 year old is when in any race
nobody can run four consecutive
marathons and not in those goofy things
but it turns out he was a member of the
Tata tribe in the copper canyons of
Mexico and he wasn't alone this is an
entire culture of people who were
running super long distances deep in the
old age I'm not getting injured and so
so this is running the old-fashioned way
that's what you're saying
right they live in another time yes yes
the thing about it is you know cushion
running shoes have only been around for
the blink of an eye in terms of human
history we've been on this planet for
two million years running shoes have
been around for thirty years so for two
million years we're relying on nothing
at all and yet now all of a sudden we're
told you know you're gonna get hurt
don't do too much buy the special shoes
get the orthotics go to hot yoga we
treat our bodies like our bodies are
these fragile little things and the
thing about it is we are really capable
capable wild animals it's just that fear
sells you make somebody afraid and
they'll buy stuff to feel safe but but
is this why you run in sandals today
because you really run in these shoes
yes and and will you run with another
technique will you use another technique
yes this is the new thing about it um
your body is perfectly equipped to
absorb a ton of shock and impact we have
all these collapsible joints the only
time that those joints become
deactivated is when you lock out your
leg and land on your heel
80% of all runners do that and the
reason why they do that is because it's
a big cushion shoe but it's very nice
with the Christian shoe it's comfortable
isn't it until you get hurt then it
doesn't feel so good so that's when you
get injuries when you run like this
exactly so we should run more
like yeah I've been bending no knees
mark you know here's a fascinating thing
so I went down at the copper canyons I
spent some times with a lot of Indians I
meet this guy called barefoot Ted and if
you have an opportunity to read the book
at some point barefoot Ted destroys all
this credibility when he drinks a cup of
his own urine at that point it's very
hard to take anything Ted says seriously
but Ted was the first guy who showed me
that you can run barefoot for a hundred
miles at a time and as I started to
research what Ted was doing it turns out
there's a law precedent on people doing
this exactly that practicing barefoot
running and doing spectacular events all
you guys didn't run the rest they are
like can you come across an angry
boyfriend that was bit you know but you
know I could take all and turn him into
a perfect runner in five seconds how do
we Craig would never catch okay here's
here's it they're they're no better
preamp okay there's a guy named Walter
George in 1870s Walter George worked
indoors sixteen hours a day
couldn't go outside the train so he
developed this exercise called the 100
up the 100 up he did inside 20 minutes a
day at the end of the first year he went
outside he broke the world record in the
mile doing this one exercise after three
years of doing nothing but this one
indoor exercise he had every world
record from a half mile to ten miles 100
up is genius so here's what you do I'll
show you first and then you can do it it
can't be easier you can't run
improperly when you're running in place
so all you do is you mark two spots on
the ground where your feet are gonna
land then you make sure your body is
straight from shoulders to hips to feet
and then all you do is this is you lift
your knee as high as your hip and as
you're your knee comes up your elbow
goes back that's it you practice that
but what happens is if your body is
off-balance in any way you'll come off
your marks so if you can do a hundred
repetitions just like this walking
making your marks then you start to run
it
toler's to it and he's laying on your
marks and you keep your knees high as
your hips your perfect runner can bond
but he can't do that you don't have to
fight it though
thank you so much for sharing sharing
this story with us and thank you your
wonderful theory Christopher
over the hive